so let's say I had the equation 2x plus
y is equal to 8 this is an equation one
single equation with two unknowns and
there's many different XY pairs that
would satisfy this equation now let's
add a second equation X plus y is equal
to five and once again if we only looked
at this second equation there's many
different XY pairs that would satisfy it
you could have X is equal to 4 y is
equal to 1 X is equal to 3 y is equal to
2 many many actually there's an infinite
number that would satisfy this right
over here but what's interesting about a
system of equations is you're using both
of these equations as constraints you're
saying is there at least one XY pair
that would satisfy both of these
equations and as we'll see in many
future videos this is a very useful
thing to think about in many not only
fields of mathematics but in many fields
of knowledge generally but the focus of
this video is to think about why the
operations we can perform on either or
both of these equations why they are
valid and why they're intuitive so the
first series of operations is when we
just try to manipulate one equation by
themselves so for example we could
multiply both sides of this purple
equation this top equation by negative 1
you would get negative 2x minus y is
equal to we multiply the right side by
negative 1 as well negative 8 now all I
did right over here this is you could do
this even if we weren't thinking about a
system is 2x plus y is truly equal to 8
we're assuming that that is true because
they're telling us that's true so if 2x
plus y is equivalent to 8 then the
negative of 2x plus y should be
equivalent to negative 8 or another way
to think about it if both of these sides
are equal if I multiply the left side by
something in order for the Equality to
hold true I have to multiply the right
side by the same thing and so this
equation on the right this purple
equation is an equivalent equation to
our original one it looks different but
the same XY pairs that satisfy this
right equation are going to satisfy this
left equate
and vice-versa now another operation
that sometimes feels a little bit less
intuitive when you first learn it when
you're solving systems is when you add
two equations together so for example we
have that purple equation the one that
we've now multiplied by negative one and
now we have our original I guess that's
teal or blue equation so X plus y is
equal to five and we learned when we're
solving systems of equations that we can
get a new equation by adding the two
left sides and adding the two right
sides and so you might have seen
something like this when we add the two
left sides let's see negative 2x plus X
would be negative X and then negative y
plus y well that's just going to cancel
out so we have no y's left and then
that's going to be equal to negative
eight plus five which is equal to
negative three and before I even go on
to try to solve this why were we able to
do that pause this video and think about
that well let me give you an example if
we had started with negative 2x minus y
is equal to negative 8 just as a single
equation and if I added 5 to both sides
of that so if I added 5 on the left hand
side and I added 5 on the right hand
side I think that would have made
intuitive sense to you negative 2x minus
y plus 5 is equal to negative 8 plus 5
hopefully this is a little bit intuitive
because what skin and I'm really saying
the same thing over and over again the
left side is truly equal to negative 8
so if I add 5 to it it's still going to
be truly equal to negative 8 plus 5 so
hopefully this makes a little bit of
intuitive sense and the key realization
with what we did up here is we
essentially added 5 to both sides you
say you might say well no no we only
added five to the right-hand side but
remember X plus y we are saying is equal
to 5 so it's just like adding the same
thing to both sides of the equation and
then when you do that that's where we
essentially were able to eliminate this
Y variable and now we got one equation
with one unknown and then from there you
can just do a valid algebraic operation
could say okay I just want to X over
here what if I were to divide both sides
by negative one and once again because
negative x is equal to negative three if
I divide negative one if I divide
negative X by negative one I also have
to divide negative three by negative one
in order to maintain the equality and so
then you're going to get X is equal to
three and so that would be the x value
of that XY pair that satisfies both and
then to figure out the Y value you would
say alright if X is equal to three I
should be able to go back into either of
these equations to find the
corresponding Y value and it's a little
bit easier to go into that second one
you could say all right 3 plus y is
equal to 5/3 plus y must be equal to 5
and then of course if you subtract 3
from both sides because once again we're
saying 3 plus y is literally equal to 5
then you're going to get Y is equal to 2
and so we found an XY pair that
satisfies both equations and really
everything that we wrote down over here
these are all equivalent statements one
of them is going to be true if and only
the other statements the other equations
are also true so 2x plus y is equal to 8
and X plus y is equal to 5 if and only
if x equals 3 and y equals 2 if and only
if negative 2x minus y is equal to
negative 8 if and only if negative x is
equal to negative 3